On the north-east coast of Germany,
looking out on the Baltic Sea,
there’s a tourist attraction
that I think is really strange.
Four of them, actually, all identical
at different seaside resorts.
And I think they’re strange
because they’re modern.
The Tauchgondel, the diving gondola,
feels like it should be
some 19th-century
Industrial Revolution invention.
It’s a diving bell: a chamber that
sinks under the water
and lets you look out
on the ocean floor.
Which is only a couple of metres
down at this point, sure,
but this isn’t like the Disneyland
fake-submarines that pretend to dive
using some bubbles and lighting tricks:
this really does go underwater.
To me, this feels like it should be
some sort of overcomplicated,
steam-powered thing
that’d entertain rich Bismarck-era
royalty for a few years,
and then fall into disrepair
and turn up in a few old photos
of odd bizarre seaside attractions
from the past.
But this?
It opened in 2009.
(IN GERMAN):
The technology here is modern.
And with modern technology comes
modern safety standards.
This gondola has the opposite problem
to most elevators:
the average tourist isn’t going to be
worried that it might fall,
but they are going to ask if it
might get stuck down there.
Or worse, that it might, uh...
...spring a leak.
[horn sounds]
[mechanical noises]
Ha! Okay.
I did not expect that.
Just... having a wave right
in your face is weird.
I didn't expect the sound.
I don't know why. But I
didn't expect the sound.
[deep, rumbling waves]
There is one slight catch, of course:
there’s not too much usually
visible in the Baltic Sea.
It’s not crystal-clear Caribbean water
on the best of days,
and today all those waves are
churning up the ocean bed as well.
So if you were hoping that sharks
or huge schools of tropical fish
would swim by,
you’re going to be disappointed.
You might get a couple
of curious flounders,
or a few jellyfish passing by.
The novelty is being on
what is, to be fair, an actual
short diving expedition
without needing scuba equipment
or a wetsuit.
But the folks here were worried that
people might be disappointed if
they didn’t see anything...
so they actually close the
shutters and show a 3D film.
If the goal was “see the ocean floor”,
well, you could do that without the chamber
and all the fancy mechanisms:
you could set down a few big walls
with thick windows in them,
pump the water out, and just have
a regular viewing gallery
that you could stand in.
But that’s not as cool.
It is a little unnerving seeing
the ocean rise around you,
out of your control,
and it’s also a bit reassuring
to surface again into the sunshine.
Because in the end,
it’s not about the fish.
It’s about the experience.